Người dân sẽ sự dụng phương thức thể bảo hiểm ý tế địa từ thân qua các ứng dụng số
và cân cứ công dân gắn chiếp khi đi tham chữa bệnh tại các cơ sở ý tế.
Người dân có thể sự dụng thể bảo hiểm ý tế địa từ bằng bà khác.
Thông qua ứng dụng về nảy ai đi, bà hiểm xa hội số,
nâng người dùng có thể hiện tị hình ảnh tế bà hiểm ý tế, tại các cơ sở khám chữa bệnh.
Người dân có thể sự dụng thể bà hiểm ý tế địa từ bằng bà khác.
Nói thông tin thể bà hiểm ý tế được tích hợp trong mục thè bà hiểm ý tế.
Sử dụng căn cứ công dân gắn chiếp để quét mát quý dờ,
trong đó đã tích hợp sử liệu thể bà hiểm ý tế.
Bà hiểm xa hội Việt Nam khuyện nghỉ người dân nên chủ đậu cập nhật và cài đặt các ứng dụng
linh quan để kiệt thời sử dụng thể bà hiểm ý tế để từ trước thời điểm ngày 1 1.6.
Vy chình đổi sá phương tức để từ không chỉ bà đà m quy lời khám chữa mạnh,
mặc còn có phần vào quá trình hiện đại hoá nền hành chính công,
phù ở với định hướng phát triển Quốc sát trong kỷ người số.